Russell Westbrook is game winner last
nightcap see 6:30 15-point assist game
of his career and against the helper
here as Melo hits it from three hello
hello bruise shot early view the Thunder
you're happy with that falls out of
Donovan Mitchell's hands as well
Tim Duncan lives Westbrook off the glass
scoring over Ingalls John's not knocking
down them how about this here the bank
shot with Russell Westbrook you love
that kind of offense and especially when
Russ is running downhill with the
basketball
quick pass inside Westbrook recovers and
blocks Mitchell wow that was a big time
block this focus where'd he come from
with no way just came out of nowhere and
got that from behind tell you what I'll
give him that
footage over vibe he's one of the guys
he needed to pay attention do tonight in
absolutely George peeps course rush Paul
George on fire shooting six out of ten
in that dribble look at this pastor this
a laser pass by Russell Westbrook to
that pass he passed that fall before
Paul George got their focal quarterbacks
do that and then I'm gonna fill basis I
know you're gonna run this route and
commit the intentional foul greenish and
OH Westbrook like the parting of the red
seas Russell puts it on Utah's head he'd
run something he just blew right by
Donovan Mitchell and went over the top
of ingles to dump the basketball but he
was hired off